[Music]
so rollerskates are making a comeback
you're gonna buy some rollerskates my
gosh let me turn my phone off I was
looking at this tyrant there's not even
blades yeah roller skate blade they're
not in roller skates our eggs are too
90s yeah I hated roller skates man wait
so the one that's like this skate but
they're cute you know what though cuz I
had hand-me-down rollerskates right and
my mom was like if you want [ __ ]
rollerblades
you got to learn how to roller skate
first so much harder too yes so I did
learn how to do it first and then she
got me rollerblades and he started
falling down a little but everybody was
already getting rollerblades so I was
the guy in the back with the roller
skates following I was like that hand me
down roller skates to because I guess I
got into right at that cusp so I had
roller skates - and then my whole street
everyone had blades and I was a [ __ ]
loser blades were too expensive my mom
said that she couldn't like they
couldn't afford it and then my grandma
ended up having to give me hers could we
share clothes I talked about a
definitive solution grandma's roller
skate I want to get some too I just
wanted to take my grandma's rollerblades
but I did I have the hand-me-down roller
skis alright so yeah so skates are going
viral at the new tic tock thing I have
both of them at home
they're so cute yeah you can't do the
moves in a row blades no I mean it just
looks like you're bigger skating and
they just looks one disco
my name is all 10 Z's and [ __ ] exactly
it makes it look cute it looks so good
man it's way easier to do within
landscapes
yeah like a more yeah I love the roller
rink to that she was tired I'm gonna try
to break my ankles I mean she's so good
[Music]
yeah so girls are going viral right now
by going rollerskating
and take time girl yeah like I know a
bunch of guys who have it right now cuz
I was thinking about getting roller
skates - no that's sick but then I'm
like it's just a generation that uses
tick-tock so anybody who uses tick-tock
regularly they're looking into getting
really but sex appeal is definitely
selling these skates cuz I'm like I want
to look cute like that there was a buff
guy bin of speech that always
roller-skated and did all these like he
was he was always there and he did so
many crazy as moves like a figure skater
it was the funniest thing cuz he always
had like a fanny pack in some short
shorts and he had like a walkie like
like a Walkman what me yeah like this
cut yeah cassette like Walkman yeah
we're not getting money or just riding
along the beach you see him living his
life no he's like he does the skatepark
sometimes or like the basketball court
and he's just doing [ __ ] twirls and
all this [ __ ]
alright living his life oh yeah and I
was like dude he's I've seen some
rollers he's in the 80s he's stuck yeah
I seen some roller skaters in the in the
skate park you know when Venice Beach
where they doing all those crazy chick
tricks
say like I've seen some roller skaters
in here doing some crazy stuff it's so
cool do you guys have a go of Venice
Beach and just like stand there watching
other people yeah it's pretty cool I
mean the corn team's making me pick up
some old hobbies though yeah okay like
I'm skating again I haven't skated in 20
years
yeah have you worked on shoutouts
shoutouts to John for bringing me this
game or Banali
sure bro that's a lot of pressure I need
all the wheels up that's a lot of
pressure
I haven't done this in 20 years you're
getting back into healthy habits I
haven't played Nintendo in 20 years and
that's all I've been doing now if I had
won I would play too but I'm just making
everyone get into like 20 years ago
what's going on now 20 year olds are
like I was zero who do I do
I have rollerblades you got wrong bottom
to walk my dogs with I mean she has
roller skates how many times have you so
how size do you wear them all the time
and I would walk all the dogs all around
cuz then I don't have to do any work and
did their technique is pulling me and
then they get to go as fast as they want
versus me having to like honey good job
yeah how do you stop them if they start
charge there's a little break up though
oh you got those damn I want to break
the most conveniently possible yeah so
we do have knee pads and a [ __ ]
helmet and risk our I fell my wrist so
many times I needed this those actually
were the most practical yeah like the
wrist guards I plucked up my hand so
let's break your fall right yeah yeah I
stopped because my brother he like tried
stopping and he it was like a crack in
the sidewalk or just you know how
sidewalks are like layered and then he
stopped and then hits the blade got
stuck in it but his body kept going yeah
it's like Snap the boot stops oh I had
it fall all the way home it just crawled
all the way home you broke his leg yeah
oh my there are no bystanders no idea
you just climb home have you guys ever
got into aggressive rollerblading in
junior high yeah fights that was fun
Esav no no like so it's like
skateboarding right where you do the
rails and [ __ ] like that but you just
[ __ ] go on your skates and you jump
and you Shh like that and it looks like
a back one light DVD and like you saw
you know there's like the whole DVD and
then like HD CD or whatever
no no blu-ray and then HD DVD so you're
not like they're two competing in a one
went away it was like that it was theirs
at the x-games back then they did beat
skateboards and also aggressive inline
skating and then I heard there's through
some like politics like to people that
were friends they weren't friends
anymore they can inline skating in the X
Games and so that's why skis just it
just only skateboard took off but back
then it was both did this happen in the
90s because the 90s like like inline
skating was so yeah in Lance Cade E and
then bikes you know yeah bikes two and a
half pipes two and they're spinning
around that and then skateboarding BMX
bikes yeah yeah and then they took out
the inline skating like if I saw a gang
of I kid rowing up to me on Robles
compared to skateboards I'd be more
afraid of the rollerblade or the
skateboarders but then you know these
two fight to like it they used to fight
all I got doing is like 100 the way that
rollerblades come up like so it
sometimes goes like against them so it's
almost like surfers fighting over a wave
so like the skateboarders need to go one
way and do it like a certain way and
then like I don't know it just did a
fire king of Healy's people come
Hailee's and I would when they made us
run in a gym I would be on the Healy's
with just when the coach wasn't watching
and then we turn around a mic it's what
the Huey's kids about the cranky they do
like scooters now like the Rangers
there's a skate park in our city and I
see a lot of kids on the racers are back
yeah I'm like wow they started coming
back especially with the electric
scooters oh like oh those are there we
don't have the electric ones this works
just as well
razors were fun I'm bummed we don't have
hoverboards the Segway kind yeah those
are so lame though like the one on Back
to the Future it's time that's cool they
actually hover above the ground why
can't you have some people making some
that work you could use over like they
come on brand mat that's made of metal
yeah so then they have the magnets that
just push off and he could use that ramp
please gotta stay in that rant though
huh yeah you go off your plate so my
backyard neighbor
I made my neighbor in the backyard they
built a halfpipe and my breath
everything I know do I want to like look
over and be like can I complain oh yeah
oh there they my current so one side
it's like a [ __ ] eight million dollar
house right like on what you saw this
side where the there's a basketball
court or it does a volleyball court and
the funny thing is there's a ping-pong
table with the pool it's like it's like
a tennis court and the ping-pong table
is like a mini size many times yeah
there's like a basketball court on the
other side they just built a [ __ ]
halfpipe there's like other [ __ ] there
there's like a bunch of stuff but they
never using it you know Mike can I use
it you're just looking at them with
binoculars with so much foam oh yeah but
they're never using it you just see
Joanna's lemon tree like yeah I'll trade
you lemons for your half way just go
skateboard neck in front of the house
and do tricks and ah I didn't yeah yeah
maybe don't fight you yeah they would be
like oh that was so bad he's not coming
I know their doorbell like the ring
doorbell they're like us that guy again
[Music]
yeah I'd like the the other one behind
us they have a basketball coach that
comes in danny has a whistle and he like
runs drills and um yeah and then all
these kids are like doing [ __ ]
basketball drills and I'm just like no
wonder they're not using their have fun
they probably got drilled on it and now
they're like oh man not ask a break yeah
I want to give myself a skateboard
ah what because I want tonight's no word
a lot and by the time summer comes
around I'm like oh I miss having like
riding a board yeah yeah I used to skim
board all the time
oh yeah Santa Barbara yeah I was like my
[ __ ] wait for like the waves to crash
to water than you run honey can you say
it like kind of you'll follow the first
couple however in a slide really far can
also get into tricks with the
skimboarding - where you slide into the
waves and you can like yeah yeah yeah
that's how a book is all going and I
guess it just didn't work out and it was
still mostly sand there so your
phosphate down it's like skills with
that it's like it's tough I want to
learn how to surf more though and I want
to learn how to do short board yeah
especially in California because our
water is not as buoyant as it isn't in
Hawaii Hawaii so easy to say what's the
difference in the waters the salt is
much it's more saltier there and so it's
more buoyant and so yeah you could float
more and you could balance yourself
better because it's more on the surface
yes I've long they have really long yeah
like he's like oh you tried a little
tiny wave and you mess up you took it
all the way back out yeah I don't wanna
go he'll the chop piece about time you
get out there tires fun yeah so those
guys those surfer guys like in Venice
they've they're really good really when
I used to surf I was like I don't know
how these guys are so [ __ ] chill I'm
just out there probably angry too about
how tired I am of getting out there and
they're just like hey man it's chill we
just fell maybe that's why because
they're so tired so much the water is
really calming to in here like salt
water is just so like huh my paddle far
enough out I don't even want to surf I'm
just sitting there used to live there
and so they're always breathing in the
salt air and being all relaxed and stuff
and you're like from the city and you're
like this is stress look at that city
boy man our to get y'all ready that's
true cuz I learned how to surf in Hawaii
and I don't think I can do it out here
cuz it's just so different oh yeah but
yeah and it's just 20 times colder too
maybe getting in the waters of battle in
Hawaii it's like oh nice yeah I can't
wait and if you fall in the water you
can actually see like oh hey starfish
already [ __ ] fall and it's just
[ __ ] Markie
[Music]
[Music]